nous sommes le 20 décembre dernier
christophe lejeune député de la haute
saône de la république la marche se rend
à la préfecture du département à vesoul
pour récupérer les clés y ait de
tolérance rédigé dans les mairies suite
aux mouvements des gilet jaune devant la
préfecture
il est pris à partie par un groupe de
gilet jaune nos confrères de l'est
républicain chp me la scène une
discussion s'engage difficilement quand
tout à coup la guillotine répéter deux
fois
des propos jugés menaçants pour le
député qui déposera plainte
l'homme qui a proféré ces menaces est
identifié c'est un ouvrier de 51 ans
après une garde à vue de plusieurs
heures il a été condamné ce matin dans
le cadre d'un plaider coupable à quatre
mois de prison avec sursis
ce sont bien sûr des menaces de mort qui
ont été ressentie très fortement par le
député qui lui même avait été dans son
propre domicile personnel menacé et
avait fait l'objet de violences de
dégradations légères il a une idée
certes flex a été posée dans sa maison
de son propre domicile particulier donc
j'entends effectivement rappelé la loi
la loi allait que en démocratie la
contestation doit se faire par les urnes
et en aucun cas par des menaces ces
personnes de 51 ans a déjà été condamné
à deux reprises notamment en 2006 pour
des faits de menaces de mort et puis il
a été également entendus dans le cadre
de procédures sur des blocages de ronds
points pour lesquels il n'avait pas été
poursuivi
nous avons joint par téléphone le député
le jeune qui ne souhaite pas s'exprimer
pour le moment mais qui nous précise
être très affecté par cette affaire et
il souhaite avant tout protéger sa
famille